[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire l'homme que je reçois
aujourd'hui est très rare à la
télévision
bernard stiegler et philosophe et
président de l'institut de recherche et
d'innovation de paris il vient
d'interpeller il ya quelques jours à
genève le secrétaire général de l'onu
antonio guterres est à la tête d'un
collectif de 60 scientifiques de tous
les pays
il lui a proposé un programme pour
repenser la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
aujourd'hui il publie le deuxième volume
de qu'appelle-t-on penser aux liens qui
libèrent pensée pnsr après l'immense
régression c'était paru l'année dernière
voici la leçon de greta tim berg greta
cette antigone dites-vous c'est une
jeune fille mais c'est d'abord une
parole et cette parole est une force
alors je vous propose de découper cette
parole un extrait c'était greenberg elle
prémunit de l'onu et son orgue chien
hatchi bassecourt pipeau fauteuil où tu
as tord my twisted words elliott monaco
x ne dit rien comme sache déjà elle ne
fait que répéter ce que nous disent les
rapports du giec depuis plus de vingt
ans maintenant pourquoi est-ce-que
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle suscite tant de
haine votre avis bernard stiegler ogier
qu'on a donné le prix nobel de la paix
on a l'impression que greta on la traite
comme si elle nous avait déclaré la
guerre à tout le monde pas tout le monde
certaines personnes oui qui n'hésitent
pas à demander qu on la tue oui c'est
arrivé
oui c'est arrivé c'est arrivé en france
série vernita lee en italie il ya
d'ailleurs une procédure judiciaire qui
est engagée en france
je me demande pourquoi on ne le fait pas
en tout cas grec est une marque suscite
des sentiments forts évidemment oui elle
dit la même chose que le jacques sauf
que
elle a 16 ans elle a d'ailleurs commencé
avec 15 et elle le dit avec eux avec une
mondiale un engagement personnel en
mettant en dix ans qu'on vient de voir
vous m'avez pris mes rêves c'est tout à
fait vrai qu'elle se révolte
c'est l'âge aussi de la révolte
l'adolescence mais elle se révoltent
parce qu'elle considère qu'on l'a privé
du droit à l'enfant à l'innocence et
c'est vrai est tout à fait vrai alors ce
qui est tout à fait extraordinaire c'est
que d'une part elle parle comme ce que
les grecs d'il ya fort longtemps de la
grèce archaïque telle que la décrivent
et michel foucault dans ces derniers
séminaires au collège de france
elle parle dans ce que les grecs de
l'époque appelait la pareille à ce que
foucault traduisait par le franc parler
c'est à dire qu'elle dit fort et
clairement ce que personne ne veut
entendre
est ce que tout le monde sait mais que
personne ne veut ton temps à savoir que
nos dirigeants ne prennent pas leurs
responsabilités ils savent très bien ce
que nous disent les scientifiques et
pourtant ils ne font rien mais ne sont
pas les seules pourraient dire et
d'ailleurs elle le dit quand as tu une
bague les adultes en général ils ne font
rien m nous avons beau savoir ce que
l'on nous dit on est conscient de la
menace
on continue de prendre date voiture de
prendre l'avion d'envoyer des photos et
des vidéos par internet de manger de la
viande et d'oeufs et d'acheter des
tonnes de fringues
elle met en cause la génération
ascendante dont elle est la descendante
et et des pays développés et guerre il
développait bien entendu maintenant je
pense que cette mise en cause
comme vous l'avait dit dans notre
présentation elle rappelle antigone
jusque antigone s'adresse
à créer un son ample mettant en cause en
lui disant qu'il n'est pas responsable
qui ne prend pas ses responsabilités
qu'il n'assume pas ses responsabilités
elle dit la même chose est
malheureusement là tout à fait raison
donc là une espèce d'ampleur tragique et
par ailleurs elle a mobilisé des
millions de jeunes gens dans le monde
en france un peu moins qu'ailleurs dans
certains pays comme l'allemagne la
belgique c'est très très important cette
mobilisation et c'est une mobilisation
salutaire parce que je que nous disent
les scientifiques en effet comme elle le
répète comme on tourne un goûter reste
n'arrête pas de le répéter et antonio
guterres est donc là ils ont invité la
secrétaire général de l'onu il ya des
vins tôt dès la côte est du tyrol et il
l'a invitée à a déclaré l'état d'urgence
voilà danser dans ses parts dans son
style dans son dans son langage et dans
un dispositif qui est véritablement
tragique en effet inquiets qui porte à
un niveau extrêmement élevé
une tragédie dans mon livre je dis que
c'est plus qu'une tragédie d'ailleurs
dont on ne veut pas entendre parler
alors qu'il est impératif de la prendre
à bras le corps et quand on nie les
rapports du giec aujourd'hui nous reste
d'après le gie acceptant pour prendre
une à tournan donc c'est extrêmement
urgent je pense que ingres et attin
blanc doit être soutenu ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il faille partager tout ce
qu'elle dit il faut discuter avec elles
avec jean marie le clézio qui j'en ai
parlé puisqu'il avait publié un article
qui s'appelait la gravité de la terre
regrettent est une merde virgule la
gravité de la terre elles étaient
frappées par ce cet article il se trouve
qu'on se connaît un petit peu non je
l'avais appelé et nous avons décidé de
créer une association l'association des
amis de la génération tony berg
pourquoi parce que nous pensons
qu'aujourd'hui faut organiser une
discussion entre cette jeune génération
qui effectivement privé de tout j'avais
moi même écrit un livret à 3 ans
consacré un autre notre jeune personne
qui s'appelle florian qui déclarait en
2005 il avait 15 ans mais malgré
trachtenberg lorsqu'elle a cessé d'aller
à l'école puis ça a commencé comme ça il
déclarait à un adulte qui lui parlait
mais vous ne comprenez pas nous notre
génération nous avons plus de créer une
famille nous avons nous n'ont pas de
travail
nous ne pourrons pas avoir d'enfants et
nous sommes probablement la dernière où
une des dernières générations
c'est ce que pense énormément de jeunes
gens et donc c'est extrêmement grave
qu'il pense là et c'est notre
responsabilité d'adultes de leur
répondre
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut leur dire
oui systématiquement à tout ce qu'ils
disent mais ça veut dire qu'il faut les
écouter parce que de toute façon ils
disent vrai tout le monde le sait
maintenant ce que nous pensons nous
c'est que ratatine bergin choses
traînent des deux choses très
importantes
elle dit écouter les scientifiques on
peut pas imaginer une position plus
raisonnable de la part de quelqu'un de
16 ans c'est formidable on entend dire
ça après elle dit lorsqu'on a vu à
l'instant ao dai ou comment osez-vous et
dans ce livre j'essaie de montrer que le
début de son appel l'anthropocène de
l'air anthropocène à partir du moment où
l'homme a eu une influence sur la
planète et à modifier la trajectoire de
l'évolution de ce qu'on appelle la
biosphère depuis 1926 le début de
l'autre grosse nc l'époque d'emmanuel
kant
c'est le début de la révolution
industrielle emmanuel kant publie la
critique de la raison pure première
édition 1781
c'est en 1980 que james watt et mathieu
boulton créent leur première entreprise
de machinisme industrielle donc c'est
vraiment tout à fait en 1176 adam suisse
écrit la richesse des nations
et à la fin du 19e xviiie siècle
emmanuel kant écrit un texte qui
t'appelle pour une revue de berlin qui
s'appelle qu'est ce que les lumières et
dans ce petit texte un article de revue
il dit les lumières c'est osé savoir
c'est ne pas craindre de savoir de
s'emparer du savoir donc il plaide pour
l'émancipation en posant comme tous les
gens de des lumières tous les
philosophes des lumières que tout
individu a une capacité de raisonner et
doit être doit penser par lui-même et
doit devenir un libre penseur
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que nous dit greta
tune bien comment osez vous c'est comme
et aujourd'hui c'est la fin des
entrepôts scène c'est la fin au sens où
le logis ac nous dit c'est la fin il
faut changer cette ère sinon la
disparaître de dents sur mon choix est
donc lld comment osez-vous alors qu'est
ce qui s'est passé pour que entre 1797
quelques et 2018
19 20 le vin maintenant ce verbe oser
changer de sens et bien il s'efface et
qui donne une norme transformation
scientifique et industrielle depuis
emmanuel kant que ces énormes sont
transformation en particulier sur le
plan scientifique d'apparition de la
question de l'entropie n'ont pas été
prises du tout en considération dans les
programmes politiques économiques et que
ça produit une catastrophe
nous nous disons quand je dis nous je
parle au nom de ce collectif jamais le
collectif internations nous disons que
l'anthropocène ce qu'on écrit avec 1 à 1
h du mot entrepose l'homme entre pose
comme marqueur d'une nouvelle époque
géologique et bien nous l'écrivons nous
entrepôts scène avec un e et sans h
comme c'est écrit sur le bandeau de mon
livre c'est à dire que ce que nous
sommes en train de lire si on le veut le
décrire d'un point de vue strictement
scientifique en mettant tout à plat
c'est une augmentation de l'entropie
l'entropie étant qu'est ce que c'est que
l'entropie
c'est d'abord une notion physique c'est
une notion qui vient de ce qu'on appelle
la thermodynamique de l'étude de
l'énergie et sa circulation
l'entropie a été d'abord si je puis dire
identifié empiriquement par un ingénieur
français qui s'appelle sadi carnot mais
qui ne l'appelez pas comme cela lui il
essayé de montrer il essayer d'optimiser
le fonctionnement des machines à vapeur
et finalement il a constaté et théorisé
le fait que l'entropie le l'énergie se
dissipe qu' il ya toujours une perte
énergétique dans le quart no c'était le
président de la république
ah non non non certains de ces dix quart
d'heure plus tard en 1850 un anglais
puis un allemand puis un autrichien ont
commencé a théorisé cette position que
sadi carnot et ça a donné la théorie de
l'entropie et qui a conduit en 1850 à ce
qu'on appelle la théorie de la mort
thermique de l'univers c'est à dire que
ces théoriciens physiciens ont dit mais
si l'entreprise la loi de l'entreprise
vraiment une loi universelle alors
l'univers va vers sa disparition en fait
vers sa mort thermique ce qu'on appelle
son cooling en anglais son
refroidissement
j'avais montré dans le tome précédent
que selon moi c'est ça qui fait que
frédéric nietzsche entre en dépression
au début des années 80 parce que
frédéric nietzsche s'est éteint un
apologètes du devenir c'est celui qui
posait qu'il fallait célébrer le devenir
et d'un seul coup le devenir c'est la
disparition de tous je soutiens qu'il a
écrit zarathoustra pour lutter contre sa
dépression et que quand il produit la
figure de l'éternel retour dans le
courant de la toussaint
en fait il préfigure ce que erwin
schrödinger en 1944 un autre physicien
est beaucoup plus tard dira dans des
conférences qu'il donne à dublin pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale où il dit
oui tout est pris par l'entreprise
mais les êtres vivants à la capacité de
retenir l'énergie et ils s'organisent
qu'ils deviennent des organismes il se
complexifie pour garder l'énergie
ils se meuvent lagarde est
temporairement ça ne vous peuvent là
mais la guerre des terres non ce n'est
pas ça que la vie n'est pas éternel elle
ne peut pas être éternel et il la garde
localement c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent
s'organiser localement alors ça c'est
extrêmement important parce que ça
signifie que il est possible
lutter contre l'entreprise même si on ne
peut jamais la battre la vaincre
définitivement on ne peut la battre que
temporairement et il est possible par
ailleurs de décrire à travers
l'entreprise
non seulement des phénomènes physiques
mais aussi des phénomènes biologiques
par exemple la réduction de la
biodiversité cindy mission de l'année
d'entropie c'est une augmentation de
l'entropie et en 1948
l'entropie devient aussi un modèle
formelle pour penser l'information ce
qu'on appelle la théorie de
l'information
donc la terrible de l'entropie devient
aussi une base pour penser le
fonctionnement des ordinateurs
alors quand on voit aujourd'hui que la
société est massivement gouverné par des
algorithmes qui font des calculs sur
tout ce que nous faisons en permanence
maintenant je crois que tout le monde en
a plus ou moins pris conscience et que
l'on voit par ailleurs le niveau du
quotient intellectuel moyen à l'air
quand même de ne pas s'élever énormément
en tout cas qu'il y a des gens qui
dirigent des états dont on se demande
vraiment comment c'est possible je dis
très souvent que donald trump même
shakespeare ne l'aurais pas imaginé il
était capable d'imaginer énormément de
choses shakespeare dans la folie des
hommes
il ya dû y avoir des rois du temps de
shakespeare qui n'était pas très malin
non plus n'ont bien entendu mais n'avait
pas la puissance de donald trump et il
n'était pas je dirais armée est entourée
comme ils le sont aujourd'hui
d'une puissance de 10 truire la planète
par exemple sur un coup de tête des
forces dit ça quand on écoute donald
trump
il n'y a pas que trump a malheureusement
disons qu'il ya aujourd'hui une bonne
défense avant qui dirigent le monde
quand même un peu partout dans le monde
c'est assez hallucinant
alors tout ça à nous deux nous
compensons que ça procède aussi de
l'entropie de l'entropie
informationnelle et le fait que ce qu'on
appelle la poste vérité et sert le fait
que les gens sont plus en plus sceptique
ya une défiance de plus en plus grande
par rapport à tous y compris par rapport
aux scientifiques dirais même surtout
par rapport aux scientifiques
c'est un effet tout cela et c'est
extrêmement inquiétant mais une des
parmi les supporters degré tête une
belle ou en tout cas ceux qui
s'inquiètent pour l'avenir de cette
planète et qui pensent qu'il faudrait
prendre des mesures
il y en a beaucoup qui accuse le
capitalisme il faudrait changer de
système créé talent
dis qu'il faut est système ne pouvait
pas corrigé il fallait changer de
système
et pourtant ce n'est pas le capitalisme
le problème si le communisme avait
l'avait emporté sur le capitalisme est
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde pouvait
être obtenir tout ce qui leur reste plus
qu il veut selon ses besoins ce qui
était la promesse du communisme le
problème serait le même le problème
c'est la presse et productivisme c'est
la production vous le dites
l'anthropocène ça commence avec la
révolution industrielle
si tous les les billets d'avion étaient
gratuits il n'en demeure pas moins que
le kérosène utilisé par les avions
continuerait de produire du
réchauffement climatique
donc qu'est ce qu'il faut si on n'accuse
pas le capitalisme
faut-il accusé le produit vis mais à ce
moment là ce qu'on accuse
c'est notre confort tout simplement est
ce confort là il ya de plus en plus de
monde sur cette planète qui prétend y
accéder alors prêté d'instigation
d'abord de dire ce que c'est que le
confort il ya un grand malaise dans la
consommation comme vous le savez ça fait
longtemps d'ailleurs c'est pas du tout
nouveau les premières grandes enquêtes
de marketing qui monte qui a un mal être
du conservateur remonte au début des
années 2000
moi j'en avait commenté une dans un
livre en 2004 là et ça c'est énorme et
mentales graves et donc ce qui était
vécu comme un confort et une espèce de
bonheur que l'art me marie can work life
était dont l'american way of life était
plus ou moins l'incarnation dans les
années 50 60 70 qui ensuite s'est étendu
au monde et qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le
consumérisme consumer's capitalisme
c'était pendant longtemps effectivement
le rêve disons on a fait ça derrière le
rêve américain etc
comme vous le savez dit rémi rivkin a
écrit un livre s'appelle le rêve
européen des intérêts américains cette
fichue tue parce que l'erreur bien sûr
beaucoup mieux mais en revanche ce que
je crois c'est que le espèce d'euphorie
tt lieu à au confort l'associé de
consommation
disons de l'après guerre et qui s'est
développée tout au long de la deuxième
moitié du 20e siècle
c'est terminé y compris en chine y
compris en chine
ça va très très très très vite la
transformation la dépression en chine
est largement aussi important qu ici
voilà le swing le taux de suicide est
plus élevé d'ailleurs
donc nous on peut considérer que c'est
le confort effectivement trop de confort
trop de marchandisation trop d'objets
tout ça peut nous faire un moment en
fait ça nous mène extrêmement mal à
l'aise parce que de plus en plus de gens
constatent que leur comportement de
shopping compulsif ce qu'on appelle ça
comme ça aujourd'hui c'est en fait à
symptômes de mal être c'est une
intoxication et que ça ne rend pas plus
heureux et ça on pas du tout plus
heureux même au contraire il ya un
sentiment de toxicité qui apparaît et
pas simplement autour de l'alcool ou du
tabac ou du café ou des substances comme
on dit mais autour des smartphones
autour de l'automobile autour de tout à
l'air de devenir toxiques avec des
vêtements d'ailleurs puisque bien
entendu des industries qui participe du
réchauffement climatique l'industrie de
la mode des joues h à son poids et on
dit que 15% des pulls ne s'en portait
qu'une fois alors des pulls qui sont
général fait du pétrole qui est qu'ils
sont non biodégradables donc c'était
absolument catastrophique non à la
question c'est de changer de mode de vie
de réinventer un mode de vie ça fait
très longtemps que je vous propose c'est
d'ailleurs pour l'europe j'avais écrit
un livre est appelée constitué de roches
disait qu'il fallait inventer un oeil au
père noël live réinventer un monde et
que ça qu'est ce que ça veut dire
est ce que ça veut dire sortir du
capitalisme ou pas je pense qu'un jour
nous sortirons du capitalisme le
capitalisme est apparue ya pas si
longtemps que ça il disparaîtra je pense
pas que ce soit dans le cadre dans les
sept ans qui viennent et le gf nous
demandent que dans les temps qui
viennent ça change
et donc je pense que la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est de repenser le modèle
industriel et de repenser la rationalité
économique en remettant en cause en
particulier je dirais moment le capital
que le travail enfin plus exactement en
remettant le travail au coeur de
l'économie et 1
réfléchissons bien ce que veut dire
travail
vous avez écrit un livre là-dessus aussi
j'en ai écrit d'eux mêmes de et et le
travail n'est pas ce que l'on croit nous
nous disons alors quand je dis nous je
plaide précisé qu'il ne touche pas les
gens avec qui je travaille ce sont
d'abord des scientifiques mathématiques
biologie surtout ce sont des économistes
ce sont des juristes comme alain supiot
ce sont des gens assez connu des
urbanistes des sociologues quand richard
sennett ça se casse à scène enfin
richard sennett qui d'ailleurs a
conseillé d'antonio guterres et ce par
ailleurs voilà ce sont ce sont des gens
qui savent plus tôt à sait de quoi il
parle il ya aussi des artistes et aussi
des activistes au monde il ya des
ingénieurs et des spécialistes du
logiciel et tous ces gens là sont
convaincus partagent une conviction
c'est que le modèle économique sur
lequel nous vivons repose sur une
physique qui totalement dépassé
c'est un modèle du xviiie siècle on
continue à résonner comme adam smith qui
lui suivait isaac newton comme emmanuel
kant mais nous ne sommes pas prêts isaac
newton
nous sommes après sadi carnot après
boltzmann après einstein
après ce running heures après beaucoup
d'autres que je ne vais pas citer
et tout ça a complètement changé le
paysage scientifique
or qu'est-ce qui fait que le modèle
industriel fonctionne c'est clean et
rationnelle si vous ne construisez pas
un avion de manière rationnelle et
s'écrase
boeing a quelques problèmes en ce moment
parce qu'il a pris des décisions
irrationnelles
ils le payent ils payent très cher les
consommateurs ont c'est un prix nobel
l'a démontré récemment le consommateur
est irrationnel dans ses choix
oui rationnelle mais l'industriel ne
peut pas se permettre d'être
irrationnels et dans tous les cas la
bourse peut pas se permettre d'être
irrationnels totalement non plus
d'ailleurs
parce qu'elle fait des corrections de
touba donc tout ça est complexe et le
composent le même la mer le consommateur
ce n'est pas un personnage unifiée sais
je suis j'ai tendance à prendre l'avion
ceci est la fin mais non il faut pas que
je fasse ça donc je réfléchis je suis un
être qui est le diagnostic disent allez
y c'est à dire que ma noesis ma pensée
divisé en deux et elle est capable de
faire le pour et le contre et de
délibérer avec elle même comme disait
aristote
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
société industrielle qui en principe si
ce qu'elle produit se vend et fonctionne
c'est parce que c'est rationnel
le problème c'est de quelle nationalité
parle-t-on nous nous appuyons beaucoup
sur un économiste qui s'appelle nicolas
georges discours organe qui était au
départ un mathématicien qui était un
roumain qui avait fui le fascisme
roumain puis ensuite de dire le
communisme room et qui a été recruté par
joseph schumpeter comme assistant parce
que schumpeter qui était donc un
économiste très connus colonist faudra
le plus connu du xxème siècle dans le
champ du capitalisme industriel
américain en particulier je me paie
terre comme tous les économistes avaient
besoin d'un métrologues se dire qu'elle
ait besoin de faire de l'économétrie
s'étire de faire des mises en équation
et se trouve que georgescu roegen était
un mathématicien donc qu'il l'a recruté
et d'orge de corgan en fait est devenu
économiste et à la fin des années 60
début des années 70 il était matin le
ciel était aussi physicien pratiquement
tous les mathématiciens sont aussi
physicien aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
appelle la physique mathématique il a
commencé objecté à à schumpeter que oui
son système marchait mais que ça
marcherait pas très longtemps
ça ne pourrait pas marcher très
longtemps parce qu'il était dans un
modèle newtonien alors que le réel est
autre pique donc ça fonctionne mais ça
fonctionne pas très longtemps par
exemple un avion fonctionne très bien
il consomme énormément de kérosène et
propre produit énormément de co2 mais
pour qu'il fonctionne il faut qu'eads
l'air ok du pétrole funky et une
biosphère et si détruit la biosphère à
terme il ne fonctionnera plus parce
qu'il a besoin la bio de la biosphère
pour fonctionner ça c'est ce que nous
sommes en train de découvrir aujourd'hui
et ça c'est ce que greta est une
bernique vous devez maintenant
travailler là dessus elle ne pense pas
comme ça mais nous par contre nous
travaillons maintenant avec n'évoquerai
donc cette association est dans cette
association nous mobilisons étudiants à
genève la semaine dernière pour discuter
avec des gens de l'onu et faire cette
conférence de presse adressé antonio
intéresse mais nous avons aussi
rencontré des jeunes
france d'angleterre de suisse qui sont
engagés dans you for climate action et
bellion et nous avons posé avec que
c'est très bien une prothèse s'ils ont
raison de protester nous pensons qu'ils
ont bien l'intention rébellion le
gouvernement britannique vient de d'en
faire une action terroriste
oui j'ai entendu dire ça cela étant dit
nous nous leur disons protester c'est
certainement utile mais la vraie
question c'est nous proposer des choses
donc discute on vous dit
nous voulons écouter les scientifiques
alors nous leur répondons ça d'abord
c'est formidable deuxièmement ce qui
fait que la science et la science est
que les scientifiques sont pas d'accord
entre eux ils sont où il ya des
controverses scientifiques aujourd'hui
une grande controverse qui avait été
lancé par niels bohr le mécanicien
quantique et einstein
elle n'est toujours pas tranchée en
physique et donc le savoir c'est d'abord
le développement une capacité à penser
par soi même et de voir que le monde se
transforme que les terroristes en somme
avec elle et ses accès
nous nous appuyons beaucoup sur la
philosophe très important britannique
s'appelle alfred whitehead qui disait
whitehead qui avait intégré la
philosophie de quand les formalismes des
mathématiques puisqu'il était
mathématicien extérieur mais qui avaient
aussi intégré l'entreprise et qui donc
essayer de penser un kantisme je dirais
sans newton mais avec les nouvelles
théories physiques et qu'est ce qu'il
disait elle la raison c'est une fonction
dans l'univers
une fonction qui est là pour lutter pour
que précisément dans la transformation
de l'univers on maintienne la
possibilité de la vie non éthique de la
vie intellectuelle exactement ce que
nombre et attenberg mais ça ça suppose
de faire tout un travail scientifique
philosophique juridique économique pour
progressivement transformer les modes de
production actuelle les faire entrer
dans une nouvelle rationalité économique
c'est pour ça que nous proposons aux
nations unies une méthode un programme
sur trois fois trois ans où on lancerait
des territoires laboratoires dans le
monde entier pour travailler sur des
questions très précises et en
développant sur la base des théories
mathématiques physiques biologiques
juridiques etc dont je viens de parler
sur la base d'un
ce qui serait un cahier des charges de
l'appel d'offres lancé des territoires
laboratoires pratiquant une recherche
contributive avec une communauté
scientifique mondiale pour trouver des
solutions et travailler avec le capital
les syndicats les associations les
habitants etc
sur toutes sortes de sujets pour faire
émerger une nouvelle économie qui soit
disons soutenable et qui soit peut-être
qu'un jour ce sera autre chose que
capitalisme je dirais que c'est pas tout
à fait notre problème pour le moment on
fait une pause bernard stiegler on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de ses
cages consacré cette semaine à vos
prévisions ollier quand je fais des
scénarios je le souhaite pas forcément
m'a toujours ce problème avec la chine
qui essaie de lutter contre l'hégémonie
américaine assez paradoxalement je pense
que la chine est plus dangereux que le
diront je pense qu'on a un pays qui est
aux abois vous savez quand les guerres
se déclenchent elles se déclenche
toujours parce que les gens ils y ont
intérêt à être 4e prévisions à lebrac
cité un éclatement de la zone euro non
moi je crois pas du tout à un éclatement
de la zone euro et j'attends même avec
une certaine impatience l'entrée de
l'école dans la zone euro alors je ne
sais pas si les causes va rétablir la
frontière est embêté la reine
d'angleterre mais en revanche l'union
européenne va avoir quelques soucis en
2020 mais c'est bien dit la crise est
derrière nous donc
ah oui donc la crise de l'euro et
derrière d'autant que le fmi je sais que
pour olivier serbie
[Musique]
à
à quels types d'élèves s'adresse cette
nouvelle proposition éducative les
enfants que nous allons recevoir nous au
cours des frères montgolfier sont ceux
qui n'ont pas atteint le seuil qui leur
permet d'être reconnu
ces élèves sont des élèves finalement
une à soupçonner qu'ils s'étaient
dyspraxiques dyslexique enfants
intellectuellement précoces nous
travaillons et c'est là notre réussite
non pas qu'ils aient un examen mais
qu'ils aient la capacité de revenir
d'une manière très confortable sur le
terrain classique tant qu'on n'aura pas
compris que nous avons nous sommes en
train de vivre un énorme tournant et un
énorme bouleversement de la pratique
d'être professeur aujourd'hui et demain
nous aurons un mal être
une somme à train de former des adultes
de demain il faut comprendre que la
france de nos banlieues et la france et
qu'il faut l'a formé et qu'il ne désire
que cela
[Musique]
de retour sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
pour continuer de discuter avec le
philosophe bernard stiegler face la
lutte face au réchauffement climatique
plus exactement que faut-il faire
je rappelle que vous voulez publier le
deuxième volume de qu'appelle-t-on
penser il est intitulé la leçon de greta
turberg il est paru aux liens qui
libèrent
j'aimerais qu'on dise un mode et déco
l'absolu des théoriciens de
l'effondrement qui pullulent ces
dernières années on leur reproche
d'encourager soit au suicide soit au
terrorisme soient les dictatures
je mets à part quelques uns comme yves
cochet qui lui nous promet 4 milliard de
morts d'ici quelques années
puis il encourage juste à s'acheter des
fusils des arcs et des flèches et à se
barricader chez soi mais mais les autres
qu'en pensez vous alors je dois vous
dire que se livrent la leçon de natation
bergues
je l'écris après avoir lu un article
dans le journal le monde diplomatique de
jean baptiste mallet qui dénonçait ce
qu'il appelle les effondre east en vrac
beaucoup de monde dont les signataires
pablo serving et c'était 27 signataires
de du livre qui s'est vendu à 70 mille
exemplaires si j'ai bien enregistrée qui
s'appelle tout peut s'effondrer
beaucoup d'autres personnes et greta
tandberg et alors il se trouve que le
livre de pabos serving
et steven j'avais lu et quand j'ai lu
l'article j'étais un peu surpris parce
que je retrouvais pas vraiment ce que
disait serving stevens et puis quand
j'ai trouvé le ton avec lequel
littéralement greta tim berg était
éreinté gants vêtements
j'étais stupéfait il était stupéfait par
ce que le monde diplomatique et un
journal que je lis depuis 50 ans
pratiquement et qui généralement
s'intéresse aux mouvements sociaux prend
très au sérieux c'est un journal auquel
on peut me reprocher tout ce qu'on veut
comme à tous les journaux il ya peut pas
être d'accord avec tout ce que disent
les journaux mais il ya un truc qu'on ne
peut pas contester c'est que c'est quand
même un journal très sérieux en général
et en plus d'ailleurs jean baptismale
est lui-même plutôt un journaliste très
sérieux il a même eu le prix albert
londres il a fait un livre que je n'ai
pas lu sur l'industrie de la tomate mais
un autre que j'ai lu sur amazon qui est
très très bien donc j'ai commencé cet
art et comme nous un chouette je me lire
un bon papier et j'ai été mais sidérait
comme quoi dès qu'on parle de
d'effondrement de fin du monde
tous nos repères sont oubliés alors
justement service ne parle pas de sens
du monde
il commence son lire non mais je parlais
de votre jour du journaliste mais lui il
dit serving par le annonce la fin du
monde mais pas du tout exactement c'est
exactement ce que le contraire de ce que
disent serving estevan s'il commence en
disant un monde disparaît mais c'est pas
la fin du monde et il va falloir
travailler à surmonter le deuil qu'on va
devoir faire de ce monde qui disent pas
il est chaud dans l'apocalypse de saint
jean il nous dit pas que c'est la fin du
monde du 10 mai l'autre monde en sortir
oui alors il dit que cet autre monde
c'est la cc le royaume non c'est le
royaume du christ bon là c'est parce
qu'ils disent toujours quand je défends
ce livre parce que je tousse sérieux et
ça ne veut pas dire quand je le défends
que je partage tout ce qui est dit c'est
comme tout ce que dit greta tout de même
je ne suis pas du tout d'accord avec
certaines choses que dictature par
contre je pense que ces démarches sont
sérieuses qu'il faut les prendre au
sérieux et qu'il faut les critiquer
critiquer ça ne veut pas dire
éreinté ça ne veut pas dire
dénoncer ça veut dire lire analyse
énoncé les limites discuter voilà alors
moi au départ le deuxième tome de cap et
on pensait ne devait pas du tout
s'appelait la leçon gartenberg du tout
du tout c'était un livre sur la justice
et le droit mais j'ai été en perturbé
dans ma trajectoire d'écriture j'écris
toujours mes livres en netteté j'ai lu
cet article 1er août les sorties de
premier route et j'ai été vraiment
choqués puisque vous avez beaucoup
réfléchir à cette question bernard
stiegler peut-on prendre ce tournant que
vous appelez de vos voeux et que tous
ceux qui prennent la menace du
réchauffement climatique au sérieux 10
parce qu'il n'y a rien d'autre à dire
il faut tourner à un moment on ne peut
pas continuer comme ça d'autant plus
qu'on est de plus en plus nombreux sur
cette planète
donc ce tournant peut-on le prendre sans
être obligé de passer par un régime
dictatorial
bien sûr que oui et est ce qu'ils sont
c'est sincèrement qu'on peut tout à coup
passer d'une société de l'abondance ou
certes tempéré par l'argent mais à une
société du rationnement parce qu'on ne
voit pas comment on pourrait faire c'est
pas la question fondamentale ou au pire
de la pénurie
je le cherche la question fondamentale
c'est celle dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure c'est le travail
ces questions je travaille moi même
depuis six ans après avoir étudié des
travaux ou de haïti et d'oxford qui ont
été très largement commentée j'avais moi
même écrit un livre dessus et en
particulier ceux de ce rapport 2ème
haïti qui montrait que 5 47% des emplois
aux etats-unis pourrait être automatisés
parce que les gens qui les font sont
prolétarisés mais il a dit aussi qu'ils
avaient peut-être un peu exagéré en
arrivant à 47%
ça pouvait être que dix noms le foyer
bas non non ce qu ils ont été mal
interprétés ils n'ont jamais dit que 47%
des enfants allaient disparaître les
descendants n'ai jamais dit ça ça c'est
fait désormais et et moi non plus j'ai
jamais dit qu'il disait ça toujours dit
qu'il disait que 47 % d'emplois sont
automatisables veut pas dire qu'ils vont
l'être
voilà aujourd'hui le scd e dernier
rapport no cd de 14 % des emplois
existants dans le monde de l' ocde dans
tous les pays de ces deux vont
disparaître c'est quand même que c'est
considérable et c'est l' ocde qui
pendant longtemps a d'abord dit 5%
d'après 7 % 10 % maintenance et 14 on
sent donc voilà il ya une tendance très
forte de toute façon il suffit de
regarder autour de l'automatisation ça
va dans l'automatisation fait
disparaître des emplois et ça pose
évidemment des problèmes de solvabilité
économique est ce que moi il ya
l'employé moyen de pouvoir d'achat -
pouvoir d'achat moyen de vente etc
notre système ne peut que s'effondrer et
l'effondrement il viendra peut-être
d'abord de cela six lits à un
effondrement au sens voilà une rupture
brutale
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait sûr mais
c'est très probable c'est très probable
c'est pas tout à fait sur moi je me bats
pour éviter ça toujours est il que dans
cette affaire la question c'est
l'automatisation au départ or
l'automatisation qu'il fondait sur les
algorithmes de calcul qu'est-ce qu'elle
génère nécessairement d'eux
entropie 7e la standardisation
l'entropie c'est ce qui élimine la
différence ce qui se tendent leur disent
tout et donc ce qui élimine la
résilience du même coup et donc ça a été
théorisée ya fort longtemps par luzy
chaude bertal en fille qui a montré
qu'un système ouvert peut se fermer un
système ouvert c'est un système vivant
qu'il faut des données d'entreprise il
peut se fermer si on le subit sous mais
à des modèles calculatoire
computationnelle c'est exactement ce qui
est en train de se passer avec la
technologie numérique
maintenant si l'automatisation et c est
possible c'est parce que 47% des enfants
américains étaient prolétarisés c'est
pas simplement les gens qui travaillent
chez ford qui ne risquent 20 general
motors qui sont à la chaîne qui sont
prolétarisés fait pas simplement les
questions de supermarché qui sont pour
l'état risée par les combats les avocats
sont prolétarisés même montré qu alan
greenspan était prêt à utiliser c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est lui donc il
s'est défendu comme ça quand il était
mis en cause au sénat américain
parce qu'on lui a demandé mais comment
je vous avais pu faire autant de bêtises
pour arriver à ce résultat en 2008 elle
a répondu mais je sais plus comment ça
marche
c'est ce que marc s'expliquer en 1900
1848 le point les terres ne sais pas
comment marche le système qu'il exploite
donc c'est lui qui sert le système alors
qu'une ville dont une devrait se servir
du système
non pourquoi est ce que vous dit tout ça
c'est parce que la politisation c'est ce
qui augmente l'entreprise par contre le
travail qui n'est pas du tout la même
chose que l'emploi le travail c'est ce
qui produit de l'année d'entropie
quelqu'un qui travaille moi je travaille
tous les matins à écrire mes livres va
produire je fais pas ça pour un emploi
je suis pas employé pour ça je fais ça
parce que j'en ai besoin j'ai besoin de
contribuer à transformer les visions des
dans le champ de la philosophie des gens
extra il y en a d'autres qui font
d'autres choses y en a qui travaillent
leur jardin d'entraver le jardin ils
inventent des choses là les vrais
jardiniers inventent des choses
travaillées s'est inventé c'est produire
c'est changer le monde
aujourd'hui l'emploi ne la plupart des
gens en tout cas les employés pour
l'état risée il ne transforme rien du
tout ils sont six ans formé e en
marionnettes et un jour on leur dit
qu'on n'a plus besoin de toi les
algorithmes font ça mieux que toi
non ça c'est insolvable économiquement
mais en plus c'est insoutenable sur le
plan environnemental
ce que nous disons nous c'est que si on
veut recevabilité
nomi capitaliste ou pas capitaliste pur
moment c'est pas mon problème mais une
économique a besoin quand même de
nourrir trois cent cinquante mille bébés
qui naissent tous les jours voilà donc
qui a besoin d'être efficiente qui a
besoin n'est pas simplement réfléchir à
son petit bout de jardin à son petit
quart est son petit village et qui a
besoin de réfléchir le niveau de la
planète
eh bien il faut repenser complètement ce
qu'on appelle la macroéconomie
maintenant ce que dit la théorie de
l'entropie et de l'année l'entreprise
c'est que la lutte contre l'entreprise
est toujours locale vous ne pouvez
jamais lutté contre l'entreprise
richesse globale
vous pouvez ne le faire que localement
c'est pour ça que se développe ce qu'on
appelle les territoires en transition
notamment dans le 93 notamment dans le
nous y travaillons nous mêmes mais il y
en a partout en fait maintenant dans le
monde entier et ses territoires qui sont
locaux il faut qu'il passe la barre de
la microéconomie parce que ce sont des
échanges microéconomie qui font qu'ils
puissent se se valoriser à l'échelle
mais au économique c'est bien au niveau
des filières au niveau des régions et à
l'échelle macroéconomique et ça veut
dire qu'il faut changer la comptabilité
de l'économie de fond en comble pour
réintégrer la lutte contre l'entropie
c'est à dire la valorisation de l'année
d'entropie ça c'est fondamental
et ça ça répond vraiment aux questions
parce que les la toxicité par contre je
travaille en ce moment moi sur la
toxicité des smartphones sur les bébés
en seine saint denis nous allons créer
avec un médecin qui s'appelle marie
claude beaud sierre qui est
pédopsychiatre devons créer une
technique contributive avec une un
centre de protection maternelle et
infantile dirigée par catherine risque
et une puéricultrice
il ya une dizaine de personnes qui
travaillent là qui s'occupe de centaines
de bébés et de mer voilà puisque les pmi
ça sert c'est fait pour accompagner les
mères qui viennent d'avoir un enfant
pour les aider dans la relation avec
leurs enfants et pour les soutenir
maternité et bien qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui il ya des émissions partout
maintenant il y en a une très bonne
d'ailleurs il ya peu de temps sur france
inter interférences interceptions pardon
interceptions qu'est-ce qui se passe il
se passe car autrement des millions de
bébés des millions de bébés qui sont
intoxiqués par les smartphones pas par
les ondes des téléphones les passeront
ils prennent les smartphones de leurs
parents les parents font pas attention
le bébé à la trappe
il serait temps à s'en servir et quand
on veut leur enlever il se met à hurler
ils sont incontrôlables
ils deviennent addict aux smartphones
est très très très vite et c'est presque
aussi terrible que le crack est une
drogue encore pire que l'héroïne canton
quand on prend une dose de crack on ne
peut plus s'en passer
alors qu'est-ce que ça produit ça vient
ça produit ce qu'on appelle le l'autisme
en fait c'est pas vraiment de l'autisme
aimé ça produit des enfants qui à deux
ans et demi trois ans ne parle pas ne
regarde pas quand vous leur parlez n'ont
pas de motricité et sont complètement
fermés en ml explique-t-on
scientifiquement passation phénomène
ça c'est en fait assez bien expliqué moi
même je travaille depuis très longtemps
sur ces questions et en particulier avec
une américaine qui est un stand ford
d'aujourd'hui qui s'appelle marianne
wolf on a publié un livre ensemble en
france et d'ailleurs et elle est
spéciale et elles et neuropsychologue et
elle a très bien montré comme morts ce
qu'on appelle la synapse tonnerre du
cerveau infantile il ya des conditions
pour qu'elle se produit dans de bonnes
dont il faut qu'ils aient des relations
d'abord très très important il faut que
les normands des changes se dissipe le
mythe de tarzan est un mythe un enfant
qui résoudrait qu'il serait levé par des
singes ne verrait jamais sosa veut se
développer dans votre cas l'enfant n'est
pas élevé par un smartphone
il n'en est par contre le d'abord les
parents eux mêmes sont toujours sur leur
smartphone c'est là que ça commence en
fait le problème
le bébé voyant ses parents son père et
sa mère sur les smartphones il veut
avoir aussi un smartphone ni veut point
de smartphones et puis on le lui donne
et quand il est sur le smartphone il est
très calme en apparence et que dès qu'on
lui enlève il fait une crise est au bout
de deux ans dans s'aperçoit qu'ils
parlent pas donc on l'emmène en
maternelle est la maternelle téléphone
aux parents mais vous savez votre enfant
est sympa
ne pas le prendre ne pas s'occuper de
lui et c'est des cas comme ça il y en a
des millions aujourd'hui c'est une
épidémie mondiale
alors pourquoi est-ce que je vous en
parle c'est parce que nous pensons que
pour soigner ce genre de choses il faut
créer un nouveau savoir avec les parents
avec les enfants
si vous demandez à un médecin un psy
carte par exemple où un médecin
généraliste ou même au patron d'orange
qu'est ce que c'est finalement un
smartphone qu'est-ce que ça produit
on ne le sait pas smartphone n'existait
pas il ya dix ans et donc il il s'est
répandue à une vitesse absolument
incroyable il a tout transformé
absolument tous les business man et d'un
temps de faire crever auchan etc etc
mais il a aussi détruit et les cerveaux
de millions d'enfants ce que nous
pensons sec dans une situation comme
celle là il faut employer des méthodes
nouvelles de recherche
c'est ce que nous appelons la recherche
contributives cette recherche nous la
menons en nous appuyant sur les
expériences en particulier de deux
grands personnages qui sont on soit au
sky à ce qu'était un très grand puis
quatre catalans 20e siècle et qui a
inventé ce qu'on appelle la méthode de
la tête thérapeutique la psychothérapie
institutionnelle félix guattari laborde
et tout ça ça s'appuyait sur un d'abord
sur les inventions de francs soit
austria ce qu'est ce qu'il va faire on
s'attend à ce qu'elle s'y retrouver
c'était amy un combattant de la guerre
d'espagne et ils ont perdu la guerre il
a dû quitter l'espagne n'était réfugié
en france il se retrouvait infirmier
psychiatrique parce que ses diplômes ne
valait plus rien en france et puis
finalement il a repassé ce diplôme il
est devenu directeur de l'hôpital
saint-alban dans les cévennes qui est un
hôpital psychiatrique et pendant
l'occupation
c'est à dire pendant le régime de vichy
et bien vous le savez peut-être on a
décidé d'arrêter de nourrir les malades
mentaux et donc lorsque ya ce qui était
un militaire autant qu'un psychiatre se
dit il a compris tout de suite ce qui se
passait et donc il a décidé de
transformer complètement la
thérapeutique il a réuni les malades
miller a dit c'est l'hôpital qui est
malade il faut vous soigner à l'hôpital
l'hôpital n'est pas capable de s'occuper
de vous
vous occupez de l'hôpital il a réinventé
complètement une économie il a sauvé de
la fin c'est ccc malade mais en plus il
a inventé l'ergothérapie et tout un
ensemble de dispositifs
alors pourquoi est ce que je vous
raconte ça parce que nous nous inspirons
de lui et nous aspirons d'un autre pôle
og américain qui s'appelle brian benson
qui est très connu et qui était le mari
de margaret mid qui était une psychiatre
une psychanalyste et gray betsson a
écrit un texte extrêmement fameux qui
s'appelle la cybernétique du soir où il
a étudié les alcooliques anonymes
qu'est ce que c'est que les alcooliques
anonymes si une association qui a été
créée au 20e siècle par d'anciens
alcooliques qui s'était désintoxiquer en
soignant d'autres alcooliques c'est à
dire qu'il se désintoxiquer on est dans
d'autres à ceux d entre eux qui coule a
depuis développé à tous les maux
imaginables oui mais sex addict de nîmes
mais les alcooliques anonymes eux ils
avaient des résultats quatre fois
supérieure aux hôpitaux américains et
donc benson qui était un homme curieux
et en anthropologie je vais étudier ce
truc là
et donc nous avons repris ses travaux
qui sont très documenté maintenant et
aujourd'hui nous avons une mis en place
une clinique dans laquelle le but c'est
que les parents avec leurs enfants qui
ont subi ce processus mais qui ont
compris d'abord grâce à marie claude
beaud sierre qui a travaillé avec eux
finalement tout ce qui se passait et ont
décidé de lutter et qui ont réussi à
sauver leurs gosses c'est à dire à
renverser la situation à l'ol
désintoxiquer du smartphone se
désintoxiquer eux mêmes du smartphone eh
bien ils deviennent comme les
alcooliques anonymes ceux qui viennent d
intoxiquer les habitants du quartier de
percer bas à saint denis
alors pourquoi est ce que vous dites
tout cela c'est parce que nous sommes
confrontés à l'échelle mondiale un
processus de désintoxication et vous
donne un exemple un autre exemple très
différent de toxicité aujourd'hui en
seine-saint-denis il ya des grands
travaux qui commencent pour le village
olympique dans la région parisienne
quand vous faites des grands travaux ou
construisent des immeubles vous faites
des fondations vous excavés des milliers
de tonnes d'argile et vous transporter
cette argile à sauf kilomètres de là
parce que c'est du déchet et c'est un
scandale parce que l'argile c'est un
excellent matériau pour
et avec les technologies actuelles avec
les robots avec toutes sortes de
dispositifs que la l'algorithme isation
du bâtiment permet de faire eh bien on
peut exploiter large et l'on peut créer
des nouveaux métiers ce qu'on appelle
mon des nouveaux compagnons des
bâtiments qui savent travailler l'argile
l'argile cru et qui l argile crue a des
qualités thermiques extraordinaire donc
on économise le transport de l'argile
on économise le coût du du béton qu'il
aurait fallu couler pour produire ce
qu'ils nient ce qui finalement a été de
l'argile mais en plus on un matériau de
construction qui est thermiquement
absolument formidable voilà vous savez
que l'arjel crucet utilisé dans le
sahara ou disons la limite du sahara
pour pourquoi pour vivre dans des
maisons
il fait 50 ou 55 dehors mais à
l'intérieur on peut y vivre
c'est un problème qui va se poser à nous
parce qu'il paraît qu'on va atteindre 50
degrés en france voilà donc quelques
années alors ce que je veux dire en
disant cela c'est que aujourd'hui la
question c'est de réinventer le travail
ne travaille en tant qu il redonne de la
valeur au savoir les savoir-faire les
savoirs pratiques les savoir vivre
ensemble et ça doit élever son enfant se
nourrir correctement ou bien savoir
mathématique et physique intégrant ces
questions dans des modèles économiques
nouveau y compris en droit en urbanisme
etc
donc tout ça c'est ce sont des vraies
réponses est ce qu'on a proposé à l'onu
c'est de lancer des programmes comme ça
on en a un qui se développe en ce moment
en seine-saint-denis à des résultats
vraiment très intéressant on n'a aucun
soutien public 1 j'en ai fait ça qu'avec
la bonne volonté d'entreprise qui nous n
vous dit bernard stiegler que pensée va
devenir l'une des activités principales
du 21e siècle penser encore une fois
panose-1 r qu'entendez-vous par là et à
quelle sorte de pansement
songez-vous alors le pansement mon livre
qu'appelle-t-on vent c'est un d'abord
une sorte de parodie d'un titre allemand
vice duncan d'un philosophe bien connu
est d'ailleurs un peu controversé parce
qu'il a un passage par le nazisme qui
s'appelle martin heidegger là
je partirai pn lui cpe n est dans le
premier volume d'ailleurs je discutent
directement avec la première partie du
deal heidegger et j'essaye de montrer
que penser avec un e
c'est forcément con c'est avec un à
heidegger disait la même chose d'une
certaine manière en 1927 dans son
premier grand livre qui s'appelle être
étant dans lequel il disait que le
penser c'est forcément la pensée pendant
c'est forcément le souci de l'être
c'est-à-dire souci org en allemand ce
qu'on traduit par soins le soin le care
le soin à l'oreille le jeune moi je ne
dis pas le caire parce que il ya toute
une philosophie du caire avec laquelle
je suis un petit peu dubitatif en la
disant il peut y avoir des choses
intéressantes dedans mais je trouve que
c'est quand même assez léger comme comme
philosophie mais en revanche ce que je
soutiens c'est que économiser c'est
toujours prendre soin économiser au sens
où on fait des économies en france ont
de l'avenir en ménage l'avenir je pense
que le soin est en effet la grande
question de demain mais quand on est un
être comme l'être humain doté d' objets
techniques et d'objets techniques qui
sont devenus aujourd'hui des objets non
seulement techniques comme par exemple
au moyen-âge là où l'art ou la charrette
mais aujourd'hui des objets
technologiques c'est à dire des fusées
des algorithmes il faut penser au sens
où il faut produire des formalismes des
mathématiques des calculs de résistance
du matériau bref il faut un savoir
penser avec un à qui passe par l'annoncé
formelle c'est à dire par les savoirs
académiques et scientifiques donc il
faut réinventer le rapport aux sciences
dans le livre
la leçon gratte attenberg ce que
j'essaye de montrer c'est que je ne
partage pas l'idée de heidegger qui est
que la science ne pense pas fait ce
qu'elle veut venir d ela sion ne pense
pas avec un e
mais par contre je sens que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la science ne pose pas
avec un a
je veux dire par là que la science en
principe au départ pour les grecs cas le
mot science tel que nous le pratiquons
aujourd'hui vient quand même avant tout
de la grèce ancienne d'abord des
mathématiciens puis des philosophes
grecs qui étaient géomètre comme disait
platon et qui était non seulement
géomètre mais physiologue ses dires
physiciens biologistes etc ils ont ils
ont comme constitué tout le le panorama
le tableau des savoirs et ça l'a conduit
à partir de descartes à ce qu'on appelle
le savoir moderne c'est-à-dire les
mathématiques la physique sont telles
que nous les connaissons aujourd'hui et
bien au départ pour les grecs
pensez au sens de du logos du noël du
delanoë this c'est-à-dire de l'activité
mentale de la réflexion délibérative non
contradictoire et formellement expressif
et expressive de la vérité veritate yves
comme les philosophes et bien elle était
là fondamentalement pour prendre soin de
la cité pour permettre à la cité de se
développer pour permettre le
développement d'une citoyenneté c'est ce
que dit exactement platon dans la
république mais c'est pas simplement
dans la république tous les textes de
platon et de tous les fils rêve
d'ailleurs de cette époque sont
consacrés à comment être bien
et pour être bien il faut penser par soi
même parce que nous avons des
possibilités techniques qui sont
dangereuses c'est que les grecs de cette
époque appel l'hubris la démesure mais
leur no tous ceux qui font des succès
des livres de développement personnel
on attend ça se moquer d'eux il ne faut
pas alors c'est un c'est devenu un
créneau riche et c'est d'ailleurs un des
sujets sur lesquels jean baptiste mallet
attaque beaucoup aussi serving et
stevens et les collabos log en les
accusant de deux prôné une approche
spirituelle de l'effondrement
je pense qu'il est de mauvaise foi en
disant ça parce que ce qu'ils disent il
faut le lire ils disent que
l'effondrement s'est produit de la
dépression c'est très vrai
malheureusement le le suicide augmente
énormément et énormément de gens sont
déprimés c'est très connu suffit d'aller
discuter avec un psychiatre
c'est malheureusement un fait et donc il
ya oui il ya une dimension mentale
spirituelle pour ça comme on veut qu'il
faut prendre en charge
il ya une éco psychologique il développe
aujourd'hui par rapport à cela
maintenant c'est un créneau le
développement personnel le bien-être etc
c'est un marché est donc évidemment il
ya quelques charlatans il ya même pas
mal si vous voulez mon avis ce que je
crois en revanche c'est que comme
l'avait dit michel foucault qui en fait
avait repris ça chez pierre hadot la
philosophie grecque c'est d'abord cette
question ce que ce que les grecs
appelaient la techno tout bio c'est à
dire l'art de vivre et whitehead
dans son livre que tout le monde peut
lire c'est un livre pas très facile mais
lisez par tout le monde doit être ça
peut être très difficile mais il ya un
livre qui s'appelle la fonction de la
raison je le recommande à vos
spectateurs de le lire dans le trou ça
se lit bien et whitehead et le rôle de
la science et de la philosophie c'est
d'abord l'art de vivre voilà donc il
faut apprendre nous devons réapprendre à
vivre la prolétarisation généralisée à
gênés en a produit à des apprentissages
et on sait plus rien faire bientôt sera
plus conduire les voitures ans et plus
élevé les enfants on sait plus compter
on ne sait plus me sont propres numéros
de téléphone par france est plus rien il
faut tout réapprendre
mais ça veut dire que vous rejetez les
ordinateurs ou les ou les smartphones
c'est pas du tout ce que je dis moi je
développe des choses comme ça à mon
institut c'est d'abord un institut de
technologie numérique
ce que nous disons par contre qu'il faut
inventer un rapport à ces technologies
qui sont dangereuses comme toutes les
technologies qu'ils soient rationnelle
et ce n'est pas le marketing qui doit
prescrire sa-7 de nouvelles formes de
savoir notre secret des académies
partout mais des académies comme on
travaille l'argile comme on sonne
l'enfant exposé aux smartphones zacademy
comme ça mais au 17e siècle
il s'est développé ce qu'on appelle la
république des lettres ça c'est fort
connue mais il s'est développé si ce
qu'on appelait les académies ce sont les
protestants départ qui les ont développé
et avait des académies partout des gens
qui
qui sonne il faut reconstituer ça les
gens le demandent et en plus les
technologies le permettent on peut avec
des technologies digitales au lieu de
faire twitter et donald trump
on pourrait faire mieux ce que je pense
ce que orange devrait faire ça avec les
amis allemands et belges et italiens qui
sont très très bons comme les français
en informatique et en télécommunications
et qu'il faut semer de l'ambition pour
donner par exemple une portance à la
politique développée ou sous la volaille
pour sauver le monde grâce à l'europe
merci bernard stiegler d'avoir été
invité dans cette émission je rappelle
que la leçon greta tim berg le volume 2
de qu'appelle-t-on pensez y aura un
troisième volume puis 23e qui s'appelle
des constructions et destruction saas
vient de sortir aux éditions les liens
qui libèrent merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]